one of the questions I get most often
from people in the comments is how can I
be more motivated and disciplined to
train or to work towards my other goals
and this makes sense because really is
the key to unlocking everything else you
want to achieve how do you force
yourself to grind on a business or side
project day in and day out when you
aren't seeing any progress how do you
wake up early in the morning to go to
the gym when you just want to roll over
and go back to sleep if we're going to
be nerdy about it and we are
Batman's only real superpower is his
discipline the answer is that you don't
force yourself you make it awesome you
make it fun you'll be completely honest
with yourself about your goals and about
what makes you feel alive and you work
towards that motivation and discipline
are driven by emotions not logic so if
you're excited by what you're doing it
won't be a chore you need to be
completely honest with yourself then
about what you want to do and what that
looks like you need to be able to
picture it and feel that emotional tug
you need to be excited when you do this
that's your vision or the quote Simon's
neck you're why this will become your
superpower and if you can't motivate
yourself to get up every morning for
that thing then this isn't truly what
you want you need to be more honest with
yourself but then you're going to forget
that vision because whilst the vision is
the inspiring end destination what's
more important of a single step you take
every single day you don't write a book
you write a page every day you don't get
into amazing shape you workout every day
the end result is provision but the
small steps are the goals the concrete
rules that you need to live by because
if you focus on the distant future it's
too disconnected from your reality it's
too easy to put off taking those steps
because you can always do it later it's
hard to stay the course because you
don't see immediate meaningful progress
many people don't even take the first
step because as soon as they do they
introduce the possibility of failure you
can't fail if you focus on those
immediate steps every day as a new
challenge and the macro goal will take
care of itself people who talk about
their grand visions and hopes but won't
take the small boring step so the ones
that never accomplished their aims my
channel now has 50,000 plus subscribers
do you know how many videos I made that
just got a few views each I did hundreds
of thousands of press-ups before I
benched 150 kilograms I can't do that at
the moment but shut up this is meant to
be motivational so how do you stay
focused on that dull grind when you
really
want the glory you make sure that you
enjoy the journey as much as the
destination to remind yourself how that
simple step is helping to make me end
vision of reality you connect the forest
to the trees watch something awesome
inspired before you train a workout that
speaks to those same emotions set
milestones and mini goals create a
feedback loop so that you can see
yourself progressing that might mean
working towards plant or increasing the
way from the barre little by little but
most of all make it awesome train like
Batman work by candle light for a
kettlebell around an abandoned tanker
with synth wave lighting and dubstep
playing in the background it doesn't
matter what other people think it
doesn't matter if it's childish or goofy
as long as you think is awesome if
others try to force you into dull
choices resist don't force yourself to
do boring work as soon as you pick up a
dumbbell or a key you become a warrior
as soon as you start typing and
entrepreneur you're living it right now
so where you end up doesn't matter all
that's left to determine is how awesome
you're going to be
you